التحول الرقمي والخدمات الرقميه والحكومه
الرقميه هي وسيله دائما اذا اصبحت غايه
فاحنا في المسار الخطا اليوم حنا ذكرنا
عشرين مليار تصرفها الحكومه على قطاع
الاتصالات تقنيه المعلومات طيب كم من
العشرين مليار هذا مستورد
68% يعني اوصف لانه منصه واحده حادخل
رحلتي كباحث عن عمل من اول ما اتخرج الين
احصل على الدعم الين احصل على التدريب الي
انا اقدم على الوظائف الين اربط بالتامات
الاجتماعيه هذه كلها منصه واحده ولا شي
صار من هذه
[موسيقى]
هذا السقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه ونعمل جريسي
استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال وقاده
الراي اتذكرها مره وصلني سؤال على لو
خلصوا ضيوف سقراط بتوقف سقراط فكان الجواب
انه اكيد سقراط حيوقف يوم من الايام بس لن
يكون السبب نقص الضيوف او انعدام الضيوف
احنا عندنا قصه تحوليه متجدده وكل مره
نلاقي يعني سبب لاستضافه ضيوف جدد واحيانا
نفس الضيف يكون فرصه لاستضافته بعد فتره
او بقبعه اخرى زي ما هو حاصل مع ضيفنا
اليوم معالي المهندس احمد الصويان اللي
صرفناه سابقا بصفته وكيل وزاره الماليه
وتحدث عن تجربه اعتماد اليوم نستضيفه
بصفته محافظ هيئه الحكومه الرقميه
ليحدثنا عن فكره هذه الهيئه ايش دورها
وايش موقعها في المنظومه بجوار بقيه
الهيئات اللي لها علاقه بقطاع التقنيه
تكلمنا على ابرز التحديات موضوع احتكار
الشركات الحكوميه
للبيانات للخدمات الحكوميه
الموضوع تعدد المنصات وارهاق المستفيد من
التنقل بين هذه المنصات على احيانا تنافس
بعض التطبيقات الحكوميه على نفس الموضوع
سولفنا عن ترتيبنا في المؤشرات الدوليه
صرفنا عن اهم الحالات اللي تعتبر قصص نجاح
حكوميه جميله في التحول الرقمي وسولفنا عن
ابرز التحديات وكيف يتم التعامل معها
واخيرا تكلمنا عن مستقبل الحكومه الرقميه
كيف شكل الخدمات الحكوميه الرقميه في عام
2030 هذه بعض محاور حلقه اليوم اترككم مع
الحوار حياك الله شرفتونا ونورت اهلا
وسهلا يسعدني جدا الله يحييك احنا بصيبه
الحلقه الماضيه اللي كانت في سبتمبر 2020
كنا نسولف على موضوع
تحدي اداره الوقت وتوزيع الوقت على
المسؤوليات الاسريه والاجتماعيه والعمل في
منظومه عمل مره متطلبه زي اللي قاعد يصير
الان في الرؤيه حتى اخر مشيه مشيناها في
حي السفارات كنفس النقاش
مزعج زملائي يعني على الاقل يوم الجمعه
بهالفتره يعني ما بين الصلاه الين تقريبا
الفتره المسائيه وانا مقدر جهودهم
يتحملوني كثير يعني طلباتي لا تنتهي
وملاحظاتي كثيره لكن زملائي جزاهم الله
خير بالهم وسيع ويتحملوني جدا وانا فخور
فيهم يعني اليوم ما تحقق في الحكومه
الرقميه وايضا زملائي في الجهات الحكوميه
انا فريقي بالمناسبه ليس فقط فريقي في
هيئه الحكومه الرقميه كل مسؤول ومبرمج ومن
يعمل على اداره الجوده او التصميم في اي
اداره تقنيه معلومات باي جهه حكوميه يعتبر
امتداد فريقي وكلي شكر وامتنان لما يقدمون
لكل المستفيدين سواء المواطنين او شركات
او حتى الخدمات الحكوميه الداخليه احنا
بصفه سعداء باستضافتك اليوم بصفتك محافظه
هيئه تحكم الرقميه الهيئه التي تاسست 2021
ومن تلك الفتره وانت تقودها
خلينا نبدا ونحكي ايش يعني حكومه رقميه
ومن متى السعوديه فيها خدمات رقميه حكوميه
طبعا القصه بدات يعني من فتره طويله يمكن
من عام 1980 او قبل ذلك لما بدات اللبنه
الاولى بمركز المعلومات الوطني لما كان
اداره داخل وزاره الداخليه ومن ذلك الحين
واحنا والله الحمد في استمرار في عمليه
تطوير يعني شامله ولكن الخمس سنوات
الاخيره وتحديدا مع انطلاق برامج تحقيق
الرؤيه كان فيه فرق كبير جدا في الخدمات
المقدمه للمستفيدين في كل القطاعات ولكن
في البدايه اظن من المهم جدا انه نعرف
الحكومه الرقميه وقبل الحكومه الرقميه
خليني اعرف مفهوم جديد اللي هو الاقتصاد
الرقمي للحكومه الرقميه جزء منه اليوم
نلاحظ يعني في كل يعني جوانب الحياه انه
القطاعات بدا يكون بينها جزء من التداخل
لما القطاع المصرفي مع قطاع الاتصالات مع
قطاع التامين مع قطاع
القطاع التجاري او قطاع الريتير نجد انه
في بينها تقارب كبير اليوم اصبح عندنا
مفهوم جديد اسمه الاقتصاد الرقمي
والاقتصاد الرقمي بكل بساطه لما حاول
اعرفه هو مستوى مختلف تماما عن البنيه
التحتيه التقليديه او ما يسمى الاتصالات
وتقنيه المعلومات وخلينا نعطي رقم عمر
يمكن عشان يوضح الفرق البنيه التحتيه
التقليديه الاتصالات وتقنيه المعلومات
اللي هي خدمات الاتصالات الخدمات التقنيه
العاديه هذه لا تمثل سوى 4% تقريبا من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي ولكن الاقتصاد
الرقمي يصل الى 14% من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي وهذا بالنسبه لنا يمثل فرصه طيب
وش الفرق بين البنيه التحتيه
خدمات الاتصالات وتقنيه المعلومات
والاقتصاد الرقمي بكل بساطه كيف نستطيع
خلق نسيج رقمي موحد ما بين الساعات والطلب
السعه اللي تقدمها خدمات الاتصالات
والخدمات التقنيه بشكلها الواسع والطلب
اللي يجي من القطاعات كل القطاعات سواء
القطاع التعليم قطاع الصحه قطاع البلديات
او غيره وفي تعريف اخر قد يكون يعني اكثر
تحديدا واكثر دقه وزع على ثلاث مستويات
رئيسيه المستوى الاول هو المستوى المعروف
اللي يسمى الكور او الاساس او الانفرس
وهذه الخدمات التقليديه اللي حنا نقول 4%
والمستوى مثل الخدمات الاتصالات
الفايبر خدمات التقنيه الاساسيه هذا
البنيه التحتيه وتمثل 4% بالضبط هذه 4%
وهذه اللي عشنا عليها يمكن 20 او 30 سنه
ماضيه وفي مستوى جديد يعني بدا خلال يمكن
السنوات الماضيه خلينا نقول من عشر سنوات
اق ل او اكثر اللي هو المستوى اللي يسمى
او المحدد وشو هذا
هذه الاعمال التي تعتمد بشكل كامل على
خدمات الاتصالات وتحديدا خدمات الانترنت
يعني خلني اوسطها اذا الانترنت توقف
توقفت هذه الاعمال ولو ناخذ عليها نماذج
بسيطه يعني على مستوى العالم عندنا اوبر
عندنا
ايضا في المملكه على سبيل المثال جاهز
وايضا اس تي سي بي فهذا مستوى جدا مهم
يربط ما بين الساعات خدمات الاتصالات
وقطاعات الاعمال وفي مستوى ثالث اللي هو
المستوى الواسع والشامل يسمى بروت وهذا
طبعا كل
القطاعات او الاعمال اللي بلا شك تستفيد
من التقنيه كجهاز داعم او كخدمات ممكنه
ولكن ليس بالضروره تتوقف اعمالها عند عند
عدم توفرها وهذا بطبيعه الحال اي شركه
مثلا تعمل سواء في البنوك او تعمل في على
سبيل المثال قطاع الغاز وبتروكي مويات مثل
انه يكون عنده نظام اداره موارد مؤسسيه او
نظام اداره علاقات عملاء او غيره هذه
المستويات الثلاثه هذه المستويات الحكومه
رقميه وين موقعكم انت الحكومه الرقميه يقع
بين السبلاي والدماد يعني هو في كثير من
الاحيان يقدم ساعات وايضا يطلب هو يطلب من
الخدمات الاتصالات وايضا يوفر خدمات
للقطاعات كلها سواء كانت القطاع الصحي او
القطاع التعليمي او خلافه ولو ولو نربطها
بحلقه ايضا سابقه مع رئيس برنامج اسمه
برنامج يسر
للتعاملات الحكومه الالكترونيه هل انتم
برنامج يسر بس اكشف يعني بقبعه بقبعه
وكرفته ولا في شيء مختلف في في مفهوم
الحكومه الرقميه عن برنامج يسر للتعاملات
الالكترونيه بلا شك يعني برنامج يسر
بالفتره يمكن ما بين 2005 2006 الين يعني
تقريبا عشرين عشرين يعني كان الهدور مهم
جدا احنا امتداد لعمليه التحول زي ما ذكرت
لك من عام 1980
بالعمل يعني مستمر في التطوير الوضع مختلف
يعني ومختلف الى حد ما بشكل كبير عن
برنامج يسر وخليني اقول الاختلافات
الرئيسيه هيئه الحكومه الرقميه دورها
الاساسي هو دور تنظيم واشراف لا تدخل في
الجانب التشغيلي ابدا
دور تشغيلي لمجموعه من المنتجات اللي تخدم
الجهات الحكوميه بينما هيئه الحكومه
الرقميه
دورها تنظيم وفي المملكه عندنا ثلاث انواع
من التشغيل
للخدمات الحكوميه الرقميه النوع الاول انه
الجهه الحكوميه تقوم باستضافه وتطوير
وتشغيل الخدمات بنفسها يعني عندها اداره
تقنيه معلومات وهي التي تشغل النوع الثاني
مثل ممكن اخذ مثال امثله كثيره يعني على
سبيل المثال وزاره الصحه البلديه والقرويه
والاسكان فيه وكاله او اداره خاصه بتقنيه
المعلومات وتقوم بتوفير الخدمات كامل هذا
النموذج هذا النموذج الاول نموذج الثاني
انه جهه حكوميه اخرى تقوم بتطوير وتشغيل
الخدمات بالنيابه عن الجهه الحكوميه مثل
عندنا في المملكه يعني عدد من الجهات
الحكوميه
يساهمون في تطوير وتشغيل المنصات ابرز
مثال لهيئه السعوديه للبيانات والذكاء
الاصطناعي الزملاء في السدايا وهي
بالمناسبه المحرك الرئيسي
لكثير من الخدمات الحكوميه الرقميه وايضا
الزملاء في المركز الوطني لنظم الموارد
الحكوميه وهم يعني دورهم مهم جدا في
الجانب الذي يتعلق بالموارد الحكوميه داخل
المثال ممكن على منصه محدده يعني على سبيل
المثال منصه اعتماد المالك لها وزاره
الماليه المشغل انسيجي ار مركز الوطن
الموارد الحكوميه منصه ابشر المالك لها
وزاره الداخليه والمشغل سدايا وهذه الفكره
بشكل عام والنوع الثالث
النموذج الثالث اللي هي لما تكون
الاستفاده من التقنيه كجزء اساسي من اعمال
الحكومات او استراتيجياتها لتقديم ايش
لتقديم قيمه
اقيمه هنا يعني شاهد مهم جدا
لكثير من الجوانب ولكن انا ببسط التعريف
خليني اقولها بلغه اسهل حكومه الرقميه
ثلاث مكونات
وثلاث مستهدفات وش المكونات المكونات
تنظيمات لازم يكون عندك تنظيم
الثاني خدمات رقميه بطبيعه الحال تبغى
حكومه الرقميه لازم يكون عندك خدمات رقميه
والمكونه الثالثه اللي هو هام جدا اداره
التغيير لازم يكون عندك مسار خاص لاداره
التغيير وش الاهداف
الاهداف لازم انك يكون عندك انتاجيه افضل
لازم يكون عندك كفاءه اعلى
ولازم تحسن من التجربه اذا كفاءه وانتاجيه
وتجربه هذه الاهداف احسها كلها واضحه
وحلوه الثالثه موضوع اداره التغيير هي
اللي فيها اكثر لانها يعني شويه مثيره
اداره التغيير هي الاهم من السهل جدا انك
تسوي تنظيمات تحط سياسات تحط معايير تحط
ضوابط من السهل انك تطور خدمات ولا حتى
تشتري منتجات تقنيه وتقول هذه المنتجات
التقنيه ممكن اني اقدمها اداره التغيير
اساس لكل نجاح اداره التغيير اذا ما كان
عندك تدريب واضح وتواصل مع ملاك الاعمال
والمستفيدين وكل الشرائح اللي انت تحتاج
انك تتاكد انهم يدخلون معك ستواجه مقاومه
وراح يكون يعني عندك تحدي كبير جدا هذا من
جانب عمر في جانب ثاني مهم جدا دائما ليس
فقط في الحكومه ولكن ايضا في القطاع الخاص
ممكن ان نقع فيه انه يتحول
التحول الرقمي او الخدمات التقنيه هدف
بذاته
متى ما تحول يعني الخدمات الرقميه او
التحول الرقمي اني انا والله هدفي اني
اسوي تحول رقمي اذا انا في المسار الخطا
التحول الرقمي والخدمات الرقميه والحكومه
الرقميه هي وسيله دائما اذا اصبحت غايه
فاحنا في المسار الخطا الهدف لازم يكون
عندك انتاجيه لازم يكون عندك كفاءه ولازم
يكون عندك تجربه افضل بعض الاحيان نجد
تنافس انه والله حنا نبغى نوقف ورق نجد
تنافس لا والله انا لازم اشتري تقنيه
معينه ولا لازم اطور تقنيه معينه يجب ان
يكون عندك مركزيه مستفيد واضحه ان تبدا من
المستفيد واحتياجات المستفيد وقطاعات
الاعمال وبعدين تشوف الحلول المطلوبه حتى
انك تصنع القيمه وتقدمها بشكل واضح مازلنا
نحاول نتعرف على الهيئه ونفهم دورها
وبعدها ندخل على اهم ما تحقق فيمكن اخر
سؤال عندي في الجانب ابغى افهم المنظومه
الماضيه كثير هيئات لها علاقه بالقطاعه
تقنيه المعلومات او قطاع التقنيه بشكل عام
تاسست وما صناعه الحدود الفاصله فعندنا
هيئه الامن السيبراني عندنا هيئه البي
الذكاء الاصطناعي عندنا هيئه الحكومه
الرقميه عندنا هيئه الاتصالات وتقنيه
المعلومات عندنا وزاره التصغره معلومات
عندنا
هيئه الفضاء الاندمجت معاهم بشكل او باخر
ودي افهم كذا بشكل مبسط مشتور هذول
اللاعبين المختلفين وليش عندنا هذا العدد
الكبير نسبيا او من وجهه نظري في الهيئات
المنظمه ممتاز انا في البدايه يمكن خليني
اتكلم عن منظومه الاتصالات وتقنيه
المعلومات
يعني معالي سواحه في مؤتمر ميزانيه رسمها
بشكل حلو رسم ثلاث دوائر
دائره الابتكار ودائره
المعلومات ودائره الفضاء وفي النص كان
تقاطعاتهم كلهم اقتصاد الرقمي هذه الثلاث
مناطق اللي هو مسؤول عنها ثلاثه فروع
رئيسيه الاقتصاد الرقمي الابتكار والفضاء
هذه الفروع الرئيسيه او المسارات الرئيسيه
لنعمل عليها وبالمناسبه خلني اتكلم عن
المنظومه المنظومه العمل فيها يمثل شرفه
على المستقبل
دائما كلنا حماس خليه نحل لا تنام دائما
عندنا هدف نحققه بشكل سريع جدا وبجوده
عاليه لا يهم
المستوى ولا يهم يعني الجانب الاداري نحط
هدف ونستطيع تحقيقه عندنا ثقافه يعني
مختلفه بشكل كبير بيئه تشجع على البحث
والتجربه نسمح بارتكاب الاخطاء الجديده
ولذلك يعني ما عندنا والله هذا في الجهه
الفلانيه خلاص هذا اختصاص ولا هذا والله
في المكان الفلاني هذا اختصاصه عندنا هدف
ويمكن احد النماذج اللي عمل في مؤتمر ليف
يمكن مؤتمر التقني الاكبر يعني على مستوى
العالم كلنا نعمل كفريق واحد بهذا الاتجاه
وهي ثلاث مسارات كما ذكرت الابتكار
والفضاء والاقتصاد الرقمي بالابتكار
شاهدنا اع
المصانع هذا السوق وفيه منظمين قطاعين
يعني على سبيل المثال هيئه الاتصالات
والفضاء والتقنيه هي مسؤوله عن السعات هي
مسؤوله عن القطاع الخاص بينما هيئه
الحكومه الرقميه هي مسؤوله عن الجهات
الحكوميه
فاحنا نمثل هنا اكثر الطلب والساعات في
الشركات موجوده
الخدمات الشركات الشركات اللي في القطاع
هم يجهزون الشركات واحنا نعمل مع الجهات
الحكوميه ويكون دائما في بيننا تواصل
ومواءمه كامله ايضا دور مهم للزملاء في
سدائر هي السعوديه البيانات والذكاء
الاصطناعي وعندهم الادوار مختلفه هم مشغل
ما في شكلي الخدمات الرقميه على مستوى
الحكومه ولكن ايضا عندهم دور تنظيمي وطني
على مستوى البيانات وهو منظم وطري
للبيانات وهم ايضا يشغلون خدمات حكوميه
رقميه مثل قناه التكامل الحكومي مثل
الشبكه الحكوميه الموحده ما تلعب توكلنا
واحسان وغيرها من منصات وطنيه حين فخورين
فيها جدا ايضا
الهيئه الوطنيه للامن السيبراني دورهم
وطني على مستوى الامن السيبراني هم يعني
دورهم جاي كده عمودي بيرتكن يعني بشكل
كامل على كل القطاعات حتى نضمن ان شاء
الله ان عندنا الحمايه والامن المطلوب
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
عبد الله شرف اليوم هذه الجهات تعمل مع
بعض يعني في بينها تنسيق عادي انا لن ادعي
اليوم ان على المستوى الشامل لا على مستوى
الشركات ولا على مستوى الجهات الحكوميه
ولا على مستوى الوظائف سواء كانت تطبيقات
ثمات او امن سيبراني او بيانات لا يزال
هناك بلا شك فرص دائما انه نراجع وفرص
للتطوير والتحسين والمهم عندنا ما في شكل
مستثم المستفيدين وايضا المستثمرين في
القطاع حتى نضمن ان نقدم لهم افضل خدمات
وافضل تنظيمات وافضل بيس استثماريه جميل
يعني انا لو بلخصها
فيه بنيه تحتيه وسعه او شبكه
وهذه هيئه الاتصالات هي المسؤوله عن تنظيم
اللاعبين فيها سواء شركات اتصالات او
شركات تقنيه معلومات صحيحه نرجعهم هيئه
الاتصالات انتم هيئه الحكومه الرقميه
المسؤولين عن كل الخدمات الحكوميه الرقميه
بالضبط انتم من في هذه الخدمات
المشرف عليها وهذه الخدمات سينتج عنها
بيانات
المسؤول عن هذه البيانات هيئه شتايه هيئه
البيانات الصناعي مسؤوله عن اداره وحوكمه
كل هذه البيانات التي تنتج عنها الخدمات
الحكوميه الرقميه وفي كل هذا العالم
الرقمي فيه خطر سيبراني ينتج عن الحصن
اليوم موجودين في الفضاء الرقمي فهنا
الدور هيئه الامن السيبراني تضع السياسات
اللي تحمي كل هذه المكتسبات الرقميه من
الهجمات السيبرانيه
مئه بالمئه ويمكن اضافه على اللي ذكرت
الجهه المشغله سواء كانت شركه او حتى جهه
حكوميه اذا كان في خدمات حكوميه رقميه هي
دائما المسؤوله هي المسؤوله عن تطوير
وتشغيل خدماتها هي المسؤوله عن بياناتها
وهي المسؤوله ايضا عن الجوانب المتعلقه
بالامن السيبراني ولكن المنظمين سواء
سدايا او الامن السيبراني او الحكومه
الرقم التنظيمات ويتابعون الامتثاء ولكن
المستوى الاخير اللي هو مستوى التشغيل بلا
شك يعني هو المسؤول بالنهايه ويضمن انه
يطبق المعايير بالشكل المطلوب جميل
يفترضنا الان فهمنا المشهد فهمنا ادوار
الجهات المختلفه تعال نتكلم بصبا خلال
سنتين من تاسيس الهيئه الان كملنا تقريبا
سنتين واربع شهور الهيئه سنتين وشهر على
قيادتك للهيئه فهو شو اللي تحقق في الفتره
الماضيه الحقيقه تحقق الكثير
ولا اظن الحقيقه انه هيئه الحكومه الرقميه
وزملائي في الحكومه الرقميه هو من حقق هذا
الانجاز ولكن الانجاز بدون ادنى شك لدى
القطاعات والجهات الحكوميه اليوم دورنا
احنا ممكن وداعم ونساعد على الجوانب اللي
لها علاقه بالتنظيم والاشراف ولكن الابطال
هم الجهات الحكوميه اسمح لي اولا اني ابدا
مع الجهات الحكوميه وانجازات في الجهات
الحكوميه بعدين نقول وش الحكومه الرقميه
ساندت فيه وخلي ني في البدايه يمكن نتكلم
عن القطاع الصحي الابطال في وزاره الصحه
بقياده معالي ابو فيصل جلاجل الحقيقه يعني
عندهم مستشفى افتراضي هو الاكبر من نوعه
في العالم يعني هذا المستشفى يربط اكثر من
160 مستشفى في المملكه ويقدم خدمات تتجاوز
200 خدمه
الهدف هنا ليس العمل الافتراضي ولكن
بالنتيجه والاثر يعني اليوم قاعدين نشوف
عمليات جراحيه لقلب مفتوح يتم اجراها عن
بعد باستخدام المستشفى الافتراضي وايضا
استطاعوا باستخدام هذه الخدمات الافتراضيه
انهم يخفضون
الاستخدام على الاسره ويزيدون السعات
تقريبا باربعين بالمئه لما يتعلق بمرضى
القلب وايضا اليوم 25% من المواعيد كلها
تقدم افتراضيه وهذا الاثر اللي وصلنا له
الحمد
ويعني لو اخذ ايضا احد النماذج في منظومه
الصحه الهلال الاحمر على سبيل المثال
اليوم سياره الاسعاف اللي نشوفها في
الشوارع يعني قاموا بنجاح جدا مبهر
واستطاعوا انهم يربطون هذه السياره
بالمستشفيات اول شيء اللي حصل اظنهم وصلوا
تقريبا 30 مستشفى وعرضت بالمناسبه في
مؤتمر ليبي الاخير الفكره بشكل مختصر ان
المستشفى يصير عارف بالحاله قبل ما يصل
البريد او تصل حاله الى المستشفى ليش لانه
ما في شك فيه قراءات حيويه كثيره في مطلوب
بيانات للطبيب وجهاز الطبي في المستشفى
انه يكون جاهز حتى انه يتدخل تحديدا فيما
يتعلق بالجلطات القلبيه طيب لما ربطنا
السيارات بالمستشفيات وش اللي صار
استطاعوا يقللون الفتره اللي يحتاجها
الطبيبه والمستشفى فتره الاستجابه من ست
ساعات الى ساعه واحده فهذا نجاح مبهر
الحقيقي لزملاء في منظومه الصحه واحنا
بالمناسبه عرضناها في قاطنا والعام الماضي
زملاء في الصحه هم من عرض
والحقيقه كانت مبهره جدا الدول الاكثر
تقدما على المستوى الخدمات الرقميه في
العالم وكيف نستطعنا من خلال الابطال في
وزاره الصحه انه نقدم نموذج رائد جدا انا
اتذكر على اسفل وقاطعتك على هذا المثال
زرت المهندس منى السبيعي صحيح وهي من قدم
بالمناسبه في برشلونه يعني هي مديريه
المستشفى الافتراضيه اخذت يعني اخذت فيني
جوله على المستشفى شفت حالات محدده لاشخاص
قاعدين يتعالجون في صعوبات النطق في في
الصوت في اشياء في حالات تبدو انها بسيطه
لكن اثرها على الانسان جوهري في اجتماعيا
وفي خلطته للناس وحديثه مع الناس وشفت
يعني بشكل مباشر لايف زي ما يقولون حالات
والتطور اللي صار في هذه الحالات وروني
مثال كان مبهر في موضوع انه احيانا
الرعايه التلطيفيه او الرعايه السريريه
لشخص ما عاد يعني تحتاج تسوي له الا انك
بس تراقب حالته فوجود الاساور او القراءات
الحيويه ومت بشكل لحظي من المركز هنا لمدن
ومحافظات في انحاء المملكه كان عندهم سرعه
استجابه اعلى من لما كانت المراقبه من
المستشفى نفسها اللي موجود في المدينه
لانها قراءه رقميه او الكترونيه فلحظيا
اول ما يعني تراجعت قراءاته الحيويه هذا
المريض مباشره اسواره او السنسر او الحساس
الموجود عنده اعطى اشاره فانقذت حالات ما
هي بسيطه صراحه تجربتهم جدا ممتازه ومشرفه
بس عشان افهم دور الحكومه الرقميه ايش كان
دورها في مثل هذه القصه عشان ناخذها كمثال
لعلاقتكم انتم بالخدمات الحكوميه الرقميه
اللي قاعده تقدمها الجهه الدور يعني هو
توفير التنظيمات المطلوبه يعني العمل مع
الزملاء في وزاره الصحه لتقديم كل الدعم
اللي هم يحتاجونه الجوانب اللي متعلقه
ايضا في المشتريات والميزانيه العمل ايضا
على تدريب الكوادر وجوانب اخرى كثيره
متعدده بلا شك اليوم اللي حصل في وزاره
الصحه ون عالمي وهو بالمناسبه عمر يمكن
يحتاج حلقه لوحده يعني التحول اللي صار في
وزاره الصحه وعندنا نماذج اخرى كثيره يعني
خليني بتكلم على وزاره العدل اسف
عشان عشان نغطي كل الجوانب لما اتكلم على
الصحه في هذا الجانب المشرق وفي الجانب
المزعج جدا هو موضوع تعدد المنصات يعني
الصحه جهاز مرتبط بناس عاده اكبر سنا اقل
احتكاكا بالخدمات الرقميه
فعلا صار في ايذاء من موضوع المنصات يعني
انا والدتي فتره الكورونا وقت التطعيمات
واللقاحات تتبهذلت ما بين منصه صحتي منصه
ما ادري وشو منصه مدري وشو فيه يعني
بعثره في المنصات ولا في ربط ما بينهم هنا
لازم يوزر نيم وباسورد لازم باسورد او
كلمه دخول ومعرف
فعلا صار الموضوع اسوا واكثر مشقه من لما
كانت بال تقليديه وهذا يتعارض مع اللي تو
حكينا عنه في البدايه انه يفترض انك تعطي
تجربه مستخدم اعلى اللي صاير في الصحه
مؤذي جدا انا اعتقد انه بحول الله تعالى
الزمره تجاوزوا ذلك واحنا عملنا معهم بشكل
مفصل على وضع يعني خارطه الطريق واضحه جدا
وقبل ايام الزملاء عرضوها في لجنه التحول
الرقمي كل القطاع الصحي
ودي ناخذها ككيس اشرح لنا بدايه رصد
المشكله اول ما رصد كيف الوصول لحل وشلون
يطبق الحل وبدي اخذها ككيس كامل هو طبعا
بالبدايه لما شفنا انه يعني كثير خلنا
نبدا من المريض يعني المريض هو اهم
مستفيده الان للخدمات الصحيه بلا شك يعني
كان في تطبيقات كثيره جدا
ولما عرضت الحاله على الزملاء المسؤولين
في وزاره الصحه وجدناهم احنا رصدناها
ولقيناها وشغالين عليها قال نعم هذه صحيحه
وبالفعل حنا نحتاج انه نعمل عليها وخلونا
نعمل معكم كفريق واحد حتى نضمن ان الخدمات
تبي تكون بالشكل المطلوب
الهدف بالنسبه لنا انه يكون في اتفاق على
التوجه وتوقف النزيف شلون توقف النزيف انك
ما تضيف منصات جديده وقفنا النزيف من فتره
يعني اعتقد من سنه الان او اكثر وبدينا
نشاهد انخفاض في عدد المنصات يعني صار
واضح عندهم انه كل فتره والله المنصه هذه
تقفل وخلاص تنتقل للمنصه الموحده لخدمات
المريض واليوم طبعا
تعدد المنصات يساعد في سرعه الانجاز وقد
يكون مناسب ترى في مرحله معينه ولكن لا
يجب ابدا انك تستمر عليه يجب ان يكون عندك
خطه واضحه ومترابطه حتى تضمن انه كل
الخدمات بتكون عندك في منصه واحده اليوم
الخطه واضحه ثلاث منصات في القطاع الصحي
منصه واحده للمريض اللي هي منصه صحتي
تطبيق صحتي كلنا نستخدمه اليوم وفي عليه
عمليه تطوير شامله ولعل الزملاء يكون لهم
فرصه معك اخوي عمر يعرضون كل التفاصيل وفي
تطبيق اخر للممارس الصحي عدم ممارسه الصحي
مهم جدا دوره يعني كل الممارسين الصحيين
ايضا لهم تطبيق خاص والخدمات اللي يحتاجها
الممارسه الصحي تختلف عن الخدمات اللي
يحتاجها بلا شك المريض بالاضافه منصه اخرى
تتعلق بالاعمال الداخليه الخاصه بوزاره
الصحه اليوم احنا هذا العمل اللي النتيجه
اللي وصلتوها منصات
يعني مقارنه بكم
انه كانت تتجاوز 20 20 فقط للمريض تتجاوز
20 واليوم يعني شفنا النتائج هذه والعمل
حقيقه فيه نموذج تحولي شامل في وزاره
الصحه متى تصير بس اعتقد قريبا جدا يعني
وقعنا مع كل الزمن يعني اللي صار عندنا
اتفاق واضح لما يتعلق دمج المنصات وخلني
اعطيك يمكن بالمجمل كل الجهات الحكوميه
نهايه العام الماضي او مو نهايه العام
الماضي يمكن تقريبا في اكتوبر في وقت
ملتقى الحكومه الرقميه كان عدد المنصات
تقريبا 816 او حولها عدد المنصات اليوم
عندنا 630 منصه لاول مره يمكن اخر عشرين
سنه بدا يقل عدد المنصات على مستوى الجهات
الحكوميه لانه صار في عمليه ضبط اليوم ما
تقدر تطلق منصه لمين ترفع طلب مبررات
واضحه الى الحكومه الرقميه والحكومه
الرقميه تراجع الحقيقه اليوم اغلب الطلبات
نرفضها ونرجع للجهه الحكوميه ونقول له طيب
انت عندك المنصه الفلانيه ولا الموقع
الالكتروني الفلاني ليش ما تقدم من خلاله
والاغلب ايضا يجي بالتاييد جهه الحكوميه
تؤيدنا وايضا لو تشوف عدد الخدمات وخلي
يمكن استطرد فيها بشكل سريع اليوم كم عدد
الخدمات الحكوميه نتكلم تقريبا عن 4600
خدمه اليوم بعد
والتاكد منها من الجهات الحكوميه وتشوف
عدد المنصات المنصات تقريبا 630 يعطيك
المعدل اقل من عشر خدمات هي المنصه
الواحده
الاشكاليه انت تفتح منصه
واحد وتحط فيه والله عدد قليل جدا من
الخدمات هذا يربك وايضا من الصعب انك تحط
يمكن 200 300 خدمه في منصه واحده هذا هو
برنامج الحكومه الشامله اليوم نعمل عليه
مع الشركاء في الجهات الحكوميه ويمكن
بستطرد عليه بس ودي اكمل ان سمحت
لانقطاعات احنا قلنا الصحه بس ما نبغى
ننسى البقيه لانهم ايضا متميزين وزاره
العدل وزاره العدل اليوم 95% من الجلسات
القضائيه تقدم عن بعد ومئه بالمئه من
الخدمات تقدم بشكل الكتروني طيب هل هذا
انجاز بلا شك وزاره العدل ما يشوفون هذا
انجاز الانجاز الحقيقي وشو انه اليوم
استغلوا عن زياره 18 مليون مراجع الى
المحاكم سنويه تبي تخيلها عمر 18 مليون
مراجع اليوم ما يحتاج يجون المحاكم
وليس هذا فقط لما نتكلم عن القيمه والاثر
والكفاءه والانتاجيه
لو ناخذ على سبيل المثال في محاكم الاحوال
الشخصيه
سابقا من يعني فتح الكيس او رفع القضيه
الين صدور الحكم كانت تقريبا بالمعدل تاخذ
حوالي 219 يوم اليوم ما تاخذ الا 30 يوم
هذا باستخدام الخدمات الرقميه والتقنيه
بالاضافه للتميز الكبير اللي عند الزملاء
بقياده معالي الشيخ الصنعاني وفريق عمله
الرائع في مراجعه الاجراءات واستخدام
التقنيه بشكل مثال المحكمه الافتراضيه
اليوم في المملكه نموذج رائد بدون ادنى شك
في اليوم لما نشوف المعايير والمتطلبات
الدوليه في المؤشرات الدوليه نفخر جدا
بقصه النجاح اللي في الصحه
وايضا قصه النجاح اللي في العدل وقصص
النجاح الاخرى اللي يخليني امر عليها ايضا
بشكل سريع انا ما ودي انسى وزاره الداخليه
وزاره الداخليه هم الرواد وهم من بدا
الحقيقه رحله التحول هذه
وذكرنا قبل شوي تقريبا حوالي 18 مليون في
وزاره العدل اللي ما يحتاج انه يراجعون
المحاكم طيب كم في وزاره الداخليه
160 مليون زياره
الى ادارات واقسام وزاره الداخليه سواء من
الجوازات او مرور وغيره اليوم ما نحتاجه
هذا هو الرقم اللي يوفر ما يصل الى 17
ريال سنويا فقط لوزاره الداخليه بسبب هذه
الخدمات المقدمه الوفر هذا مو بس عن
الحبوب ولكن ايضا على المواطن وهذا له اثر
واسع الارقام اللي نذكرها اليوم في العدل
وفي الداخليه وفي الصحه وفي القطاعات
الاخرى هذا يقلل الانبعاثات الكربونيه هذا
يخفف من الزحام هذا يساعدنا على تقليل
التكلفه ورفع الكفاءه والانتاجيه بشكل
كبير وهذا اللي نشوفه اليوم باثر واضح
الحقيقه في قطاعات مختلفه
ذكرنا مجموعه امثله ودي افهم ايش هي
الممارسات اللي ما ترضيكم احنا ما حنذكر
امثله عشان ما نورتكم مع اي احد بس ايش هي
الممارسات اللي اذا لاحظتوها مباشره
تدخلون تتواصلون مع الجهه وتح اولون
تعملون على تجاوز مثل هذه الممارسه ضربنا
مثال في الصحه بكثره المنصات اللي تتعب
المراجع او المستفيد وش في ممارسات اذا
لاحظتوها تبداون تدخلون ممتاز طبعا احنا
اليوم عندنا برنامج الحكومه الشامله يتعلق
بحوكمه المنصات عندنا برنامج اخر مهم جدا
اللي هو رحلات الحياه اللي
لا نقبل فيه ابدا انه ان تعمل الجهات
الحكوميه بشكل منفرد اليوم لا يهم من هي
الجهه الحكوميه التي تقدم الخدمه ولا يهم
ايضا وش المنصه اللي تقدم الخدمه انا
قدامي حكومه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
حكومه المملكه العربيه
سيفين ونخله حنا نقدم خدمه واحده ما يهم
احلام ما بين بعض الجهات الحكوميه وما بين
يعني قنوات التواصل ما بيننا المفروض اننا
ننجز العمل ونعطي التجربه والكفاءه
والانتاجيه فهذا اليوم ما نقبله ونسعى
طبعا مع شركائنا في جهات حكوميه كلها
لضمان يعني تقديم الخدمه بشكل المطلوب
والشرحلات الحياه والحمد لله صار فيها
نجاح سواء في الاسكان ولا ايضا في
المواليد خليني اخذ على سبيل المثال
المواليد هذا عامل مميز ما بين وزاره
الصحه
والمستشفى ليتبع وزاره الصحه وما بين
وزاره الداخليه ووكاله الاحوال المدنيه
اليوم المولود تدخل على منصه واحده اللي
هي منصه تبشر وتوصل لك شهاده الميلاد وكرت
العائله بشكل واحد ما يحتاج تروح لوزاره
الصحه ولا تروح للمستشفى هذا ربط كامل من
خلال الخدمات والاصول التقنيه اللي موجوده
عندنا اللي يساعدنا نقدم الخدمه بشكل
المطلوب اليوم اللي نسعى له وايضا لا يزال
امامنا عمل كبير في المستقبل انه نضمن انه
اليوم في عمل مشترك وتنسيق ومواعظمه كامله
ما بين كل الجهات من خلال برنامج
الاصلاحات ورحلات الحياه حتى نضمن ان
الخدمات مقدمه بالشكل المثالي للمستفيد
واحنا ايضا نسمع يعني غير برنامج الحياه
احنا عندنا قنوات متعدده نظما نسمع بشكل
مثالي المستفيد فاذا لاحظنا وجود مشكله
يتم رصدها بشكل مباشر التواصل مع الجهه
الحكوميه تقديم الدعم اللازم للجهه
الحكوميه حتى نضمن انه ما في تاخير
وبالتالي معالجتها بشكل المطلوب وارغب
واكد انه صراحه لا نجد الا استجابه مباشره
ودعم كامل وتواصل ولله الحمد الاغلب يتم
حله في وقت قصير جدا
[موسيقى]
يعني اسمح لي بالصبا افضفض شويه في
الجزئيه انا في هالمبنى هذا تحديدا سمعت
في 2021 عن موضوع الرحلات
الرحلات الشامله او او رحله المواطن وحتى
خذوني في جوله وشفت اللوحه الضخمه وفيها
كم عدد الرحلات وكانوا يقولون في نهايه
2021 حنخلص ثلاث رحلات في نهايه 2022
حنخلص تسع رحلات اليوم احنا 23 ولا في ولا
رحله اصبحت موجوده بالشكل اللي وصف لي انا
وصف لانه منصه واحده حتخل رحلتي كباحث عن
عمل من اول ما اتخرج الين احصل على الدعم
الين احصل على التدريب الين اقدم على
الوظائف الين اربط بالتامات الاجتماعيه
هذه كلها منصه واحده ونفس الشيء البحث عن
سكن
الايجار التملك القرض الافراغ الربط مع
ملاك اتحاد ملاك كل هذه منصه واحده
ولا شيء صار من هذه يعني نسمع عن الرحلات
بس ما بعد شفناها طيب ممتاز هل ما صار شيء
في الرحلات ما اعتقد انه هذا دقيق وش صار
فعل صار مثلا في رحله المسكن رحله المسكن
اليوم موجوده عند الزملاء في وزاره
الاسكان وتستطيع اليوم المنصه سكني تمشي
بالرحلات كامله في رحله مهمه جدا قياده
الزملاء في وزاره التعليم ايضا تسجيل طلاب
الصف الاول الابتدائي ولكن برجع المنصه
الواحده ذكرت واحده
وهذا ياخذني الحديث في البدايه هل المنصه
الموحده غايه هي غايه انا اقول
الغايه هي رضا المستفيد وتقديم التجربه
المطلوبه والكفاءه والانتاجيه الى اخره
اليوم خلنا نشوف دول العالم افضل دول
العالم في الحكومه الرقميه حسب المؤشرات
الدوليه على الاقل يعني شوف مثلا تطور
الحكومه الالكترونيه الاول دوله الدنمارك
هل عندها منصه واحده الجواب لا لا يوجد
عندها منصه واحده عندها اكثر من المنصه بس
ما عندها 600 منصه ما عندها 600 منصه بس
ما عندها منصه واحده الناس 600 منصه كنا
قبل سنه 800 سنه 600 ونبي ننزل الان ولكن
اذا انت فكرت انك تحطها بمنصه واحده
يتحول
الغايه او الوسيله تتحول الى غايه او الى
هدف انا اظن
انه اليوم يجب ان نطبق مفهوم الحكومه
الشعبيه خلي بس بتكلم شوي عن الحكومه
الشامله تكلمنا عن دمج المنصات لازم تقلل
مو معقول عندك 600 منصه هذا غير المفروض
انك تنزل بشكل كبير جدا طيب وش بعد لازم
يكون عندك خدمات مشتركه وش خدمات مشتركه
او المكونات المشتركه لازم يكون عندك نفاذ
موحد لازم تكون عندك قنوات قنوات دفع
واحده لازم يكون عندك قناه تكامل واحده
شبكه موحده بمعنى انك جيت تسوي منصه
تعتمد على نفس المكونات بحيث انه ما يتغير
عليك كثير من الاشياء ولا تحتاج انك
تسويها من البدايه
وايضا جانب ثالث مهم جدا احنا بديناها
اليوم ونتوقع ان شاء الله يعني خلال سنه
او سنتين يعني راح نشوف نتائج واللي هو
توحيد التصميم
لما تاخذ فكره مثلا الكود العمراني على
مستوى المدن كيف انك توحد الكود العمراني
هذا اللي اليوم حريصين على عمله في
الحكومه الشامله حيث انك توحد نظام
الالوان
توحد هيكل التصميم وين تحصل يعني القائمه
المنسدره او دروب داون ميني وين تحصل
والله الاوبشنز او الخيارات الموجوده بحيث
اذا دخلت على ابشر ولا ناجز ولا اعتماد
ولا قوه ولا اي منصه تقريبا تشوف نفس
الشيء ولكن يمكن اللوجو يختلف
والمحتوى يختلف وبنفس الوقت نعطي الفرصه
للجهات الحكوميه انها تتحرك وتنجز بشكل
كبير
اكثر ما يميزنا في المملكه بلا شك موضوع
المنصات فيها تعدد اكثر ما يميزنا في
المملكه هو
توافريه الخدمه او السيرفس
ويمكن ندخل على بعض الامثله اللي نقارن مع
دول العالم وخليه يعني مثلا على سبيل
المثال اخذ
تجديد اصدار وتجديد رخصه القياده اليوم
هذي بالنسبه لنا شيء عادي موجوده على منصه
ابشر ويعني نعتمد عليها بشكل كبير اليوم
هذه الخدمه غير متوفره في افضل دول العالم
اللي هي دوله الدنماركي في الحكومه
الرقميه ولكنها موجوده عندنا اليوم وهذا
واضح اليوم على سبيل المثال لو ابى اخذ
الوكالات
واحنا زملاء في وزاره العدل قبل اربع
سنوات
اوقفوا اخر وكاله
في المملكه المتحده يوكي لا يوجد عندهم
وكالات رقميه بل انك قد تحتاج انك تتوكل
محامي حتى انه يروح المحكمه ويخلص لك
الوكالات والشكل المطلوب ايضا لو تاخذ على
سبيل المثال
الخدمات البلديه رخص الانشاء سواء تبي
تاخذ اذن ولا اتمام بناء او كذا اليوم
اللي موجوده على منصه بلدي بقياده الابطال
في وزاره الشؤون البلديه والقرويه
والاسكان اليوم في كوريا الجنوبيه اللي هي
افضل دوله ايضا في مؤشر البنك الدولي حق
نضج الحكومه الرقميه هي رقم واحد اليوم
الخدمات هذه ما هي موجوده تطلع نموذج لازم
انك تعبيه وتروح تراجع في القطاع فهذا
اليوم هذا اللي موجود في المملكه اليوم
نحتاج نتوازن نحتاج نوحد الكود نحتاج نوحد
المكونات نحتاج نقلل المنصات ولكن نضمن
انه بالنهايه الهدف ما يكون عندك منصه
واحده
ولكن تضمن ان الخدمه بالشكل المطلوب وعندك
يعني العدد المطلوب من الرحلات ما زلت
مؤمنين فيه يعني
تدمجون ماصات في وزاره واحده هل ممكن نشوف
دمج عده منصات في وزارات مختلفه في منصه
واحده او رحله واحده احنا ما اتوقع طبعا
السوبر اب اللي هو كل الخدمات الحكوميه في
مكان واحد 4000 خدمه في مكان واحد ما هو
منطقي بس على الاقل رحلتي اللي مرتبطه
بمثال قطاع الاعمال هل اقدر كرجل اعمال
اني القى كل خدماتي في منصه واحده اليوم
وزاره مواد البشريه عندها اكثر منصه فانت
تدخل عشان شيء ثم تطلع وتدخل على المنصه
ثانيه عشان شيء ثاني ثم تبتل فقطاع
الاعمال برضو قاعد اليوم يعاني من تعدد
المنصات وكل واحد 24 ساعه سكرتير يكلمه
جاك كود عطني الكود تجربه ما هي جيده فهل
احنا نتكلم على مفهوم رحلات انه هذه كلها
تدمج في منصه واحده ولا الهدف التقليص
المنصات كل وزاره عندها منصه واحده ودي
مشروعك ومش مشروع بالنسبه طبعا لقطاع
استعمال بلا شك اليوم في عمل كبير وفي
منصه موحده للاعمال يعمل عليها الزملاء في
وزاره التجاره والمركز السعودي للاعمال
طبعا بقياده معالي الدكتور ماجد وايضا من
خلفهم الجهات الحكوميه اللي هم زي ما ذكرت
العمل التامينات الاجتماعيه
ايضا الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك وكل الجهات
الهدف بكل تاكيد انه يكون مكان واحد تدخل
عليه وتحصل الخدمات والمكان هذا ما يكون
فقط هو عباره عن واجهه ولكن تكون اجراءات
مترابطه تعطيك الخدمه بشكل المطلوب ذكرنا
قبل قليل المواليد وهذا المستهدف بكل
تاكيد على يعني لما يخص قطاع الاعمال
بدينا خطوات يعني على هذا الموضوع
والزملاء الحقيقه اليوم لو تدخل موجوده
بزنس موجوده وبقياده الزملاء الحقيقي
العمل فيها كبير جدا واعتقد قطعنا شوط جدا
ممتاز ونبي نشوف الان
ذكرت لوزاره الشؤون البلديه عفوا وزاره
الموارد البشريه والشؤون الاجتماعيه
الوزاره طبعا فيها قطاعات مختلفه يعني
فيها قطاع للعمل
وفيها قطاع للشؤون الاجتماعيه وفيها قطاع
ايضا يتعلق
بيسمى الموظفين الحكوميين او الخدمه
المدنيه يعني ثلاث قتلات قطاعات رئيسيه ما
يتعلق بقطاع العمل هو فقط منصه قوى وهي
المفروض تقدم كل الخدمات ومنصه قوى
بالتنسيق بدون شك مع الزملاء في المركز
السعودي للاعمال يكون بينهم المواعم
المطلوبه لتقديم الخدمه الوحده اللي فيها
كل ما يخص عالم الاعمال فيتامينات
الاجتماعيه غرفه تجاريه قوه تراخيص الرخص
المحلات حقتي هل هذا توجه اذا ايه متى
نتوقع نشوف هذه المنصه الموحده هذا طبعا
العامل اللقائم اليوم يعني هل في تاريخ
اليوم محدد امانه ما اقدر اعطي تاريخ لكن
الزمل الحقيقه في وزاره التجاره والمركز
السعودي لاعمال يعملون عليه
شك هذا المشروع وهذا الهدف وناس عادي ضمان
ان النتائج تكون عندنا بالشكل المطلوب
وابغى ااكد انه المنصه الموحده ليست هدف
حنا نبغى الرحله ونبغى التجربه بالشكل
المطلوب حتى نضمن انه ما يكون عندنا
تحديات هذا الهدف ويعني نبغى نضمن انه لا
في تصميم الاجراءات ولا طبعا قبل
الاجراءات السياسات وتوفير الخدمات
الرقميه وترابط المنصات فيما بينها نحقق
الهدف المطلوب ذكرت يمكن بعض النماذج الان
في الاسكان ولا كذلك في المواليد لان ابغى
نفس التجربه تكون بهذا الشكل ويكون عندنا
هيكل موحد مترابط بالشكل المطلوب يمكن من
الاشياء اللي دائما تذكر لما نحكي عن قطاع
الخدمات الحكوميه الرقميه هو موضوع
الشركات الحكوميه التقنيه
المشهد انت تعرفه كل وزاره تسوي لها شركه
تقنيه وهذه الشركه تاخذ خدمات هذه الشركه
واحد الوزاره وتحولها وتصير هي اللي ماسكه
بياناتها وبعدين تبدا تبيع هذه البيانات
او تكون مسؤوله عن عمليات الربط فلقينا
فجاه عندنا سته سبعه شركات تقنيه حكوميه
احتكرت خدمات هذا الوزارات فودي افهم وش
راي الحكومه الرقميه في هذا الحراك اللي
قاعد يصير من الشركات التقنيه الحكوميه
ممتاز خليني افصل في علاقتنا مع القطاع
الخاص الى ثلاثه مسارات رئيسيه المسار
الاول هو ما يتعلق بالمشتريات اللي هي
التكلفه زائد يعني هامش الربح
اللي هو على نظام المنافسات والمشتريات
الحكوميه اليوم يعني في عمل كبير في هذا
المسار يعني لو نحاول يعني نحطه في رقم
تقريبا حوالي 20 مليار ريال هذا اليوم
اللي تشتري الجهات الحكوميه من قطاع
الاتصالات وتقنيه المعلومات سنويا سنويا
اللي هو الكوست بلس هذا طبعا في عمل كبير
الفتره الماضيه ممكن ابرزوا ما يتعلق
بالاتفاقيات الايطاليه والسوق الالكتروني
الان عندنا اربع اتفاقيات ايطاليه سابقا
كنت تحتاج تنتظر 100 يوم من الطرح الى
الشراء حتى انك تحصل على المنتج اليوم خمس
ايام فقط واحد الامثله مثلا اللابتوب على
سبيل المثال من الجهه الحكوميه تبغى تشتري
تدخل على السوق يعني عندنا اشبه بامازون
داخل الحكومه تشتري والمورد يجيبه عندك
وهذا طبعا بالشراكه مع الزملاء في منظومه
الماليه وزاره الماليه وهيئه كفاءه
الانفاق وايضا الزملاء بالمركز
ايضا تصنيف مقاولين يعني الشراكه مع
الزملاء في وزاره البلديات عندنا تصنيف
مقاولين واضح وهدف تصنيف المقاولين انه
نركز على الشركات اللي تعطينا القيمه
العاليه ما يكون عندنا شركات عباره عن
اعاده بيع او بيع وبالتالي ما يكون عندي
القيمه المطلوبه جهه الشركات اللي تركز
على البحث والتطوير والابتكار وصناعه
المنتجات وعندها تركيز محدد يعني في تقنيه
ناشئه او في مجال معين
وحقق له يعني خلال هالفتره القصيره يعني
الان تقريبا حوالي مليار ونصف ريال
الوفورات المحققه من مراجعه الكراسات من
تقديم التدريب من وضع النماذج وراجعه
استخدام الدوائر الرقميه وغير من مجالات
ولا نزال نعمل حتى نضمن انه هل يعني السوق
هذا يكون بالشكل المثالي
وعلاقتنا مع القطاع الخاص تكون دائما يعني
بالشكل المتميز ويكون في فرصه للشركات
انها تدخل في هذا السوق بالشكل المطلوب
هذا النوع الاول النوع الثاني هو ما يتعلق
بالمشاركه بالدخل يعني نماذج المشاركه
بالدخل اللي هي ايضا ترتبط بنظام
المنافسات والمشتريات الحكوميه وايضا
بالقرار الوزير الوزاري الصادر من معالي
وزير الماليه ابو فيصل
وهذا طبعا مسار مهم جدا اليوم بلا شك فيه
مشكله وفي تحدي اليوم في احتكار
في ضعف في حوكمه الاسعار ولا في تنافسيه
وش سوينا طيب خلال الفتره الماضيه سوينا
بيئه تنظيميه تجريبيه
تقريبا كل الشركات الله يعطيهم العافيه
وسجلوا في البيئه التنظيميه التجريبيه
وسجلناه تقريبا اغلب المنتجات عندنا ما
يزيد عن خمسه وخمسين منصه ومنتج اليوم
تقدمها هذه الشركات للجهات الحكوميه
وبحول الله تعالى يعني نعمل السنه هذه 20
23 راح نعلن عن الاطار التنظيمي لترخيص
اعمال الحكومه الرقميه اللي هو راح يعالج
التحديات اللي موجوده اليوم وانا اؤكد
فعلا انها موجوده ونحتاج انه ما يكون
عندنا احتكار وتكون الاسعار منطقيه جدا
وايضا ما يكون عندنا تحديات لما يتعلق
بجوانب التنافسيه
وجدنا الحقيقه من كل الشركات كل التعاون
وكل الشراكه دورهم مهم جدا كان خلال يمكن
العشرين سنه الماضيه وسيظل دورهم مهم جدا
في المستقبل وهم شريك اساسي
ونعمل معهم باذن الله تقديم القيمه
الكبيره النوع الثالث غير الكوست بلس وغير
النوع الثالث هو ما يتعلق باتاحه الاصول
الرقميه وهذا مهم جدا لرواد الاعمال احنا
حريصين اليوم كحكومه انه نوفر
الاصول الرقميه بكل رواد الاعمال والشركات
حتى انهم يقدمون خدمات وتطبيقات ذات قيمه
ويعني يمكن ابرز مثالين اللي هي البيانات
المفتوحه
بحيث انه نضمن البيانات متاحه في رواد
الاعمال اليوم عندنا ما يزيد عن 6000
مجموعه بيانات متوفره وايضا ما يتعلق
بالواجهات البرمجيه الواجهات البرمجيه
اللي هي الاي بي اي سواء كانت للاستعلام
عن البيانات او حتى كانت عملياتيه او
ترانزاكشن البيست بحيث انه يربط مع الجهات
الحكوميه هذا يساعد على الابتكار ويساعد
الحقيقه على تقديم يعني بيئه تنافسيه
مثاليه في كل الثلاث مسارات احنا نعمل ليس
فقط
بكل الثلاث مسارات نعمل
وسع يعني بحول الله تعالى نقدم كل ما
نستطيع حتى نضمن الشراكه المثاليه مع
القطاع الخاص لدوره مهم جدا خلال الفتره
الجايه انتم انتم راضيين على
الممارسات الاحتكاريه من شركات اللي
مربوطه بوزارات محدده بلا شك بلا شك اليوم
نعتقد انها فتره ويعني قد يكون لها
اسبابها الفتره الماضيه اليوم نرغب
المراجعه ونرغب فتح السوق ونرغب يكون في
حوكمه الاسعار وبالنهايه هي اصول حكوميه
وسنضمن باذن الله طبعا انا عندي قناعه
كامله انه سيكون او لا يزال هناك فرصه
للنمو
والتوسع لهذه الشركات حتى مع وجود التنظيم
لما يتعلق بهذه الاصول الفرصه اليوم
موجوده والقطاعات يعني ما شاء الله واعده
عندنا قطاعات كبيره اليوم واعده داخل
الحكومه وفيها استثمار كبير وانا متاكد ان
هذه الشركات دور مهم جدا وهو الخطوره
مصيبه وانت تخطر مني يمكن هذا كذا استطراد
على مجلس فكانوا يقولون انه خطوره هذا
النموذج انه قاعد يصنع زي ما صار مثلا في
طفره
2005 الى 2015 الطف كانت كل المشاريع
الحكوميه قاعده تتركز على شركتين مقاولات
كبرناهم ضخمناهم ما عطينا فرصه لباقي
السوق وصلنا اسرى لهم لما طاحوا
انكشف قطاع المقاولات واكتشفنا لانه ما
عندنا احد مؤهل قادر يبني مره الطفره ولا
صنعنا ابطال في قطاع المقاولات ما نبغى
طفره الحكومه الرقميه والتحول الرقمي تعدي
ونكتشف انه ما عندنا ثلاثه اربعه لاعبين
عايشين على وزارات محدده وحتى هم هذولي ما
قدروا يبيعون برا حدود الوطن لانهم خلاص
شبعانين بالعقود اللي هنا لم تبنى عضله
التسويق البيع للخارج
المنافسه مع على مستوى اقليمي ومستوى دولي
لانه خلاص هو شبعان بالعقود اللي قاعده
تجي من الجهه وطفشنا القطاع الخاص طفشنا
الشركات الصغيره المتوسطه طلعناها من
السوق لانه هذا جالس على بحر من البيانات
محتكرها الحاله وعقود ملياريه سنويه
المشهد للجميع خساره مضاعفه المستفيد
الوحيد هي الوزاره لانها لقت احد توظف فيه
موظفينها برواتب عاليه وتجيب في مواهب
فيعني المشهد فعلا ما هو صحي
واثاره الاقتصاديه خطيره ومن زمان نسمع عن
كلام فيه حتى حرقتي مع معالي عبد العزيز
الزوم هيئه
التنافسي هيئه المنافسه كان في حديث على
هالجانب بس اللي واضح انه الكعكه قاعده
تكبر لهذه الشركات ما هو العكس حتى اول
شركات رخصتوها هي علم الثقه والتكامل
فيعني ما زلنا في نفس البحر ندور على
هالاسماء هذه
يمكن مدخل جديد على موضوع التراخيص
لهالشركات طبعا انا ما اظن التحدي بهذا
المستوى مقارنه مع قطاعات اخرى ويمكن ذكرت
المقاولات في فتره سابقه
لا التحدي ان شاء الله يعني قادرين على
السيطره عليه لا يزال في دور كبير لشركات
من القطاع الخاص بالاضافه للشركات
الحكوميه ويتم الاعتماد عليها بشكل كبير
البيئه التنظيميه التجريبيه ليش رخصنا
للشركات هذه احنا رخصنا عشان ننظم
الاماكننا نعرف البيانات يعني اول سؤال
طيب وش الخدمات هذه كم مقابلاتها وش
تصميمها وش تفاصيل العقود هذا فكره البيئه
التنظيميه التجريبيه انت الان تبغى تعرف
الاساس حتى تستطيع انك تخطط المستقبل
وتبدا يعني بشكل يعني مدروس وواضح ومتدرج
يعني تفصل وش الخطوات اللي تحتاج انك
تسويها هذه الشركات دخلت
يعني سجلت معنا بشكل كامل والتفاصيل اليوم
موجوده والان في الاعتمادات النهائيه ان
شاء الله قريبا باذن الله وخلال هذا العام
نبدا الاطار ونبدا عمليه الترانزيشن صعبه
انت عندك مسار جديد ونبغى نتوسع فيه اللي
هي المنصات المنتجات الجديده للشركات
المرخصه كلها يعني ليس فقط هذه الشركات
وطبعا عندنا المسار العقود القائمه وكيف
ننقل العقود القائمه من وضعها الحالي الى
وضعها الجديد احنا ايضا حريصين انه نظما
انه ما في تاثير على الخدمات احنا
بالنهايه المستفيد يهمنا بشكل كبير ونبغى
نضمن ان العمليه الجراحيه هذه تتم يعني
بشكل مثالي
من يملك البيانات هل الوزاره كل وزاره
تملك بياناتها ولا منه المالك للبيانات
اللي موجوده في الجهات الحكوميه هو طبعا
انا اعتقد انه الوزارات هي المالكه
للبيانات بلا شك يعني اليوم الوزاره هي
تملك الخدمات تملك البيانات الوزاره او اي
جهه تملك الخدمات تملك البيانات وطبعا في
تنظيمات واضحه يعني لها مرجع واضح تحدد
ذلك ويمكن التنظيمات تفصل يعني قد اكون
انا ما عندي تفاصيل بشكل كامل لكن الزملاء
في مكتب البيانات الوطنيه عندهم التنظيمات
التي تحدد يعني كافه الممارسات والاجراءات
المطلوبه حتى انك تتعامل مع هذه البيانات
ودي افهم هنا وش عاده دوركم في مثل
الحالات انا على مثال زرت منصه الحوادث
المروريه في
مركز السلامه المروريه اعتقد كذا اسمه
وكان عندهم داش بورد رائع جدا على موضوع
الحوادث المروريه وتوزيع الجغرافيا
وتوزيعها
الزمني وتوزيعها مناطقيا كانت منصه رائعه
جدا مثلهم ما شاء الله هذي كل حوادثنا
قالوا لا هذه بس اللي تباشرها وزاره النقل
قلت وين الباقي ما قالوها بس اللي انا
فهمته انه واضح الحوادث اللي عند البلديه
ما اعطوهم اكسس على هذا المعلومات الحوادث
اللي باشرها المرور ما عطوهم اكسس على
المعلومات الحوادث اللي يباشرها الهلال
الاحمر ما عطاهم فطلعت عندنا منصه مشوهه
ما تعطي الا جزء من المعلومه بينما لو
تداخلت كل هذه المعلومات في مكان واحد
لاصبحت القيمه من هذه المنصه اعظم بكثير
هل هذا ضمن ملعبكم بما انها منصه حكوم ولا
هذه تبع هيئه البيانات الزملاء طبعا اليوم
في السدايا عندهم منصه استشراف على سبيل
المثال كل البيانات اللي تجي من كافه
القطاعات حتى انها تكون في منصه واحده
تساعدنا باتخاذ القرار ويعني استخدمناها
في كثير من الحالات يعني سواء لا في
التعليم لو في الاسكان او في غيره بحيث
انه ناخذ البيانات من اكثر من قطاع وتكون
موجوده عندنا في مكان واحد حتى ناخذ
القرار المناسب
وبالمناسبه يمكن ذكرت قطاع النقل قد لا
يكون الحاجه عندهم انه يحتاج كل البيانات
موجوده قد كده حطيت كل شيء اللي في
البلديات واللي في المرور يعني بيكون من
الصعوبه التعامل مع اللوحه هذه لاحتياج
وزاره النقل او هيئه النقل هي على حسب
الاحتياج انت وش تحتاجه اليوم ما في تحدي
بتوفير البيانات
التحدي اللي ذكرنا قبل شوي هو يتعلق
بالنماذج التجاريه عندنا تحدي في الاحتكار
صح البيانات موجوده والجهات الحكوميه
تتناقل البيانات وعندنا بالم شبه بنك
بيانات وطني موجود عند الزملاء في سدايا
والبيانات موجوده فيه مثل ما احتجناها
نستطيع ان نطلع فيها يستخدم التحدي تجاري
ويتعلق في الاحتكار والتنافسيه وهذا اللي
ان شاء الله جاري العمل عليه والتسعيره
تدخلون فيه يعني كان كثير يتكلمون على
تكلفه الربط مع ابشر ولا تكلفه الربط مع
منصه اكس او واي او زد انها في رسم عالي
جدا ولا يفرق ما بين شركه عملاقه وما بين
شركه ناشئه بلا شك هل تدخلون في بلا شك
يعني هذا من الاهداف وطبعا تتكلم عن
التحقق والنفاذ وكافه هذه الخدمات يعني
حنا حريصين اليوم انه نراجع هالاسعار
ونتاكد انها يعني مناسبه للشرائح المحدده
من المستفيدين وكل الخدمات الاخرى يعني
حتى نضمن انها بالشكل المثالي اتذكر في
وثيقه رؤيا لما اعلنت لما اطلقت في 2016
كان احد الاهداف
المنصوص عليها في عام 2030 هو ان نكون ضمن
افضل خمس دول
الحكومه الالكترونيه
وين وصلنا في المؤشرات الدوليه عندنا يمكن
اربع مؤشرات دوليه او يمكن خلني قبل
الدوري عمر خلنا نتكلم عن المحلي وش
المؤشرات المحليه اللي اشتغلنا عليها حتى
يكون عندنا ربط واضح مع المؤشرات الدوليه
عندنا حاليا اربع مؤشرات المؤشر الاول هو
قياس التحول الرقمي وهذا بلا شك انه
يستهدف الجهات الحكوميه يعني المنظم
الحكومه الرقبيه والجهه التي يتم العمل
معها اللي هي الجهه الحكوميه وهذا صار
عليه تطور كبير ابتداء من عام 2021 هي
السنه اللي انطلقت فيها الهيئه
واليوم يعني تحولنا الى
الامتثار يعني الان صار عندنا وضوح في
المتطلبات والاستجابه المطلوبه المؤشر
مؤشر تحول الرقمي في الجهاز
هنا احسن ثلاث جهات في هذا المؤشر اعتقد
وزاره العدل
الاولى في العام الماضي الثاني اعتقد انها
وزاره الموارد البشريه القوائم طبعا كلها
موجوده على موقع الهيئه يعني ممكن اي احد
يحصل عليها هو اعلانات في وقته حلو هذا
الاول الثاني ما يتعلق بالمنتجات اللي هو
النضج التجربه الرقميه او السيكس وش فرق
انه عن قياس النضج يركز على المنتج ويشرك
المستفيد الاول قياس يشوف الجانب المؤسسي
النضج لا يشوف المستفيد وراي المستفيد
ورضا المستفيد وتجربته يعني على سبيل
المثال العام الماضي اللي شارك معنا
تقريبا حوالي عشرين الف مستفيد في تقييم
المنصات كان عندنا اظن 12 منصه السنه هذه
باذن الله راح نوصل 24 منصه وباذن الله
راح نتجاوز 100 الف
مستفيدون اخذنا رايهم عطونا تقييم وعملنا
استبيانات كامله بالاضافه الى ما يسمى
بالمتسوق الخفي او المستري شوبينج احنا
نروح وندخل
ونشوفه طبعا هذه لها ايضا ضوابط ومعايير
واضحه الثاني نضج الخدمات النضج التجربه
الرقميه مين افضل اثنين فيه اعتقد ابشر
كان هو الافضل العامل الماضي وان شاء الله
السنه هذه تشوف من الافضل عندنا عدد اكبر
السنه هذه كانت 12 السنه هذه 24
نستهدف 24 وباذن الله العام القادم يكون
عندنا عدد اكبر ايضا المؤشر الثالث الثالث
يمكن اللي اعلنا عنه قبل كم يوم وهو يتعلق
بالمستقبل خاص
تقنيات المستقبل جاهزيه الجهات الحكوميه
لتبني التقنيات الناشئه وهذا مهم جدا
لوضع مسار واضح لحكومه المستقبل اليوم لما
يجينا متطلب من قطاعات الاعمال داخل
الحكومه حريصين جدا انه ما نفكر بس نسوي
منصه ولا نسوي موقع الكتروني نبغى نشوف
التقنيات الجديده نبغى نشوف درونز نبغى
نشوف الذكاء الاصطناعي نبغى نشوف السلاسل
الكتل او البلاكتين ولله الحمد يعني طبعا
في البدايه هو اول مره نطرحه وسويناه بشكل
تجريبي اعتقد شارك معنا 13 جهه حكوميه
واعلنا الجهات عشر جهات اعلنت اول جهه
كانت هيئه الاتصالات ثاني جهه كانت وزاره
العدل وجدنا نماذج رائده جدا الحقيقه
ويمكن اهم التقنيات المستخدمه كانت واضحه
اللي هي الميتافيرس
او الواقع المعزز الذكاء وهذه كانت بارزه
بالمناسبه في البلديات والاسكان انه هم
يحتاجون الثري دي ويحتاجون عرضها بشكل
متميز وايضا ذكاء الاصطناعي كان واضح جدا
سلاسل الكتل ايضا موجوده بشكل جيد الدرونز
ايضا شاهدنا نماذج الدرونز بالذات عند
البلديات وكشف الحفر والان نبغى ندفع بهذا
الاتجاه بشكل كبير للاعتماد على التقنيات
بالشكل المطلوب وهذا مهم يعني يمكن حكومه
المملكه
يعني من
افضل الدول التي تركز على هذا الجان ليس
فقط الجانب التقليدي من الخدمات الرقميه
ولكن ايضا على تقنيات المستقبل والشهر
الرابع يتعلق بالمحتوى الرقمي وكفاءه
محركات البحث وهذا طبعا احنا نعمله بشكل
تجريبي داخليا مع الجهات الحكوميه ما
نشرناه الى الان لكن ان شاء الله خلال سنه
من اليوم راح ننشر باذن الله افضل مئه
موقعه ما يستهدف فقط الجهات الحكوميه
الجهات الحكوميه وشبه الحكوميه ايضا
هدفه طبعا
انه يتاكد ان المحتوى اللي موجود في
المنصات في المواقع الالكترونيه موجود
بالشكل المثالي يشوف الجوده
يشوف التحرير يشوف الصور يشوف ظهورك في
محركات البحث مثل جوجل وغيره وهذا مهم جدا
بالنسبه لنا اليوم المملكه لاعب دولي مهم
جدا فاحنا حريصين انه ليس فقط توافريه
الخدمه وليس فقط رضا المستفيد ولكن لما
يكون عندنا
محتوى يعني جيد وجوده جيده وتحرير وصياغه
جيده وظهور على محركات البحث هذا راح
يساعد في ظهورنا بشكل المثالي هذه الاربع
مؤشرات الداخليه
انتم تقيسون فيها بتساعدكم في تحسين
موقعنا في المؤشرات الدوليه بالضبط قبل ما
نروح مؤشرات الدوليه مين متعبينك
من الاربعه المقصود للاسلامين الجهه
الحكوميه اللي ما فلحت في الاربعه بالعكس
انا ما في عندنا جهه حكوميه ابدا لا يوجد
وعلى فكره لما جهه حكوميه
يعني تطلب دعم ولا جهه حكوميه تقول ما
اقدر ولا جهه تقول حكوميه تقول امرك
الساعات احنا عندنا فرق خاصه لدعم الجهات
الحكوميه والمتابعه معها بالشكل المطلوب
احنا بالعكس يعني اذا هم ما جونا ترى حنا
نروح لهم طب نقول ترى المستفيد عنده
ملاحظات في بعض الجوانب اللي تحتاج دعم
اليوم
الافضل بس ما تعلمون بقيه الترتيب فما
ندري من هو الاسوء انا مقصوده هذه بلا شك
مقصوده ليش احنا نعرف من هو ترى اللي في
اقل او اسفل القائمه وداخل الحكومه هذا
معروف ويرسل
يروح له تقرير ويعني فيه تقارير متابعه
كامله بس ما هو ضروري انه نعلم من هو
الاقل احنا نقول منه الافضل عشان نحط
المنافسه والتحفيز المنافسه هذه مهمه جدا
وشفناها باخر سنتين وهذا برضو ترى كان
يعني من الجوانب اللي فكرنا فيه كثير في
البدايات ننشر ولا ما ننشر وكان فيه يعني
جدل كبير يعني داخل الهيئه على هذا
الموضوع انا كنت انادي دائما في النشر بعض
زملائي يعني كانوا عندهم نوع من التخرج
طبعا وصلنا لاخر صياغه احنا خلنا نرسل
المتميزين على الاقل وكما لاحظت يمكن
الاربع مؤشرات او ثلاث مؤشرات اللي نشرت
احنا ننشر المتميزين هل نبي ننشر اللي اقل
من ذلك ما عندنا خطه هنا الان لكن اعتقد
الوضع الحالي يعني قاعد يساعدنا بشكل كبير
وقاعد يظهر جوانب التميز يعني على سبيل
المثال التقنيات الناشئه لما نشر يعني جت
لي يعني كثير من الاشادات من منظمات دوليه
انه كيف المملكه استطاعت انها تطوع
وتستفيد من التقنيات الناشئه لانه هو ليس
فقط انك تحط رانكينج وترتيب تقول والله وش
سوت وزاره الزراعه وش سوت وزاره البلديات
وش سوت وزاره العدل وكيف استخدمت التقنيه
ولهم كلام انشائي بالارقام نحط ارقام
واضحه وم حدده كيف سعادتنا يعني اننا نخلط
قيمه بالشكل المطلوب الاربع مؤشرات هذه
كلها لها طبعا يعني معايير محدده ومناظير
محدده
نحاول نربطها
بحد كبير جدا مع المؤشرات الدوليه حتى
نساعد زملائنا في الجهات الحكوميه على
العمل بشكل مثالي ابدا يمكن اذا سمحت
لناخذ المؤشرات الدوريه نبدا الاول اللي
هو طبعا الاقدم اللي هو مؤشر تطور الحكومه
الالكترونيه هذا اللي اسمه
هذا طبعا ينشر من الامم المتحده وبدا
يعني تقريبا من 2001 بدا كبنش ماركو 2003
اعتقد كان اول يعني صدر
وبدايته كانت مع انتشار الانترنت لما طلع
الانترنت بدات الامم المتحده بالتفكير
بهذا المفهوم
صح وهذا اللي موجود كان في وثيقه الرؤيه
وطبعا في ثلاثه عناصر رئيسيه والفكره من
خلال هذا المؤشر انه يحاول يربط اكثر من
جانب هو صحيح اسمه تطور الحكومه
الالكترونيه لكن هو ما يقيس الحكومه
الالكترونيه الثلث فقط يقيس الحكومه
الالكترونيه والثلثين يقيسون شيء ثاني
واتكلم عنها الثلث الاول حكومه
الالكترونيه او يسمون الاو اس اي الخدمات
الحكوميه الالكترونيه
وهذا طبعا الخدمات المعروفه اللي موجوده
اليوم سواء في الصحه في التعليم خدمات
الافراد خدمات البلديات
وهذا الحقيقه يعني في عليه تركيز كبير
ونتابع مع الزملاء بالجهات الحكوميه مربوط
بالمؤشرات الاخرى بالشكل المناسب الثلث
الثاني الثلث الثاني يتعلق بالبنيه
التحتيه والفكره هنا هم ليش حطوا البنيه
التحتيه خدمات الاتصالات لانه يقول
بالضبط يعني انت لو عندك مشاكل في المناطق
البعيده لو عندك مشاكل في الكونكتيفيتي او
في الاتصال او حتى بالاخفورد انك انت يعني
حتى لو الخدمه موجوده الناس ما تقدر تحصل
عليها لاي سبب
فبالتالي لا راح يعطيك سكور قليل وعندك
فيها تحدي فبالتالي الثلث يقيس البنيه
التحتيه حتى يضمن عندك البنيه التحتيه
المثاليه
والثالث هو يتعلق بالهيومه كابيتال او راس
المال البشري وايضا الفكره هنا تتعلق
بالاميه والقدره على يعني التواصل مع
الخدمات الرقميه والقراءه والكتابه ومستوى
التعلم وبالتالي الفكره يقول اذا هو مو
متعلم بالتالي قد يواجه صعوبه انه يعني
يتعامل مع الخدمات الالكترونيه يمكن حنا
ولا الحمد للمملكه ما نشعر فيها بس كثير
من الدول عندهم هذا التحدي انه ما يستطيع
انه يتفاعل معها بالشكل المطلوب العام
الماضي 2022 حققنا المرتبه 31
مقارنه مع المرتبه ثلاثه والاربعين في عام
2020 وطبعا النتيجه المحققه هي افضل نتيجه
تاريخيه
حققتها المملكه كانت افضل نتيجه اعتقد في
20146 والان الحمد لله احنا في المسار
المرتفع ولا يزال الطموح كبير تسالني تقول
والله هل حنا فعلا 31 من 192 دوله اقول لك
بلا شك انه افضل من 31 وذكرت بعض النماذج
قبل قليل وهذا اللي ثبت بالمؤشر الاخر
اللي هو المؤشر نضج الحكومه الرقميه اللي
هو الجي تي ام اي او الجفت من البنك
الدولي ما يقيس 192 دوله
ولكن يقيس 198 دوله يعني حتى اخذ دول من
خارج اعضاء الامم المتحده المملكه ولله
الحمد الثالث على العالم المملكه الثالثه
على العالم وهنا لما اتكلم عن توافريه
الخدمه توافريه الخدمه اثبتت يعني في نضج
الحكومه الرقميه الصادر من المجموعه البنك
الدولي انه المملكه متميزه جدا وسبقنا
الدنمارك سبقنا استونيا سبقنا امريكا
سبقنا المملكه المتحده كندا ودول اخرى
كثيره
لما وضعنا النسيج بشكل كامل ورينا انه
الخدمات والاستخدام من هذه الخدمات ورضا
المستفيدين منها بالشكل المطلوب الاول مهم
والثاني ايضا احنا لا نزال نتابع الاول
والثاني وقد هنا يكون في معايير وهنا في
معايير طبعا معايير في نضج الحكومه
الرقميه تختلف شوي او تختلف كثيرا يعني عن
التطور الحكومه الالكترونيه الاول والثاني
عفوا في هذا المؤشر
الثاني اعتقد انه البرازيل البرازيل اعتقد
ان البرازيل عندهم ما هو عندنا ليش هذول
الاثنين تفوقوا علينا البرازيل طبعا
النتائج مقاربه جدا يعني حنا 97% وكسور
يعني قريبه جدا الفرق ما هو كبير البرازيل
متميزه ايضا بتوافريه الخدمه وحالتها يعني
فيما يتعلق بتوفير الخدمات مشابهه كوريا
الجنوبيه قد يكون عندهم حوكمه يعني افضل
حنا تحدثنا قبل قليل عن حوكمه المنصات
والجوانب اللي نحتاج نركز فيها
كوريا الجنوبيه والدنمارك عندهم هذا
التميز يعني ونحتاج الى نصل له بالشكل
المطلوب ولكن احنا عندنا خدمات افضل انا
ذكرت لك قبل ق المثال الخدمات البلديه
خدمات البلديه ترى ما هي موجوده هناك
لكنها موجوده في المملكه بلا شك هذه الدول
عندها دروس مستفاده كثير ممكن نتعلم منها
ولكن ايضا حنا عندنا التميز في الخدمات
يمكن بشكل افضل من العديد من النواحي في
مؤشر ثالثنا عليه قبل التصوير اللي هو
مؤشر الياباني او في جامعه وسيده جامعه
وسيده وطبعا يعجبني جامعه وسيده انا بعض
الاحيان احب اطلع من المنظمات الدوريه
لها اعتباراتها الخاصه ولها بعض الجوانب
اللي تحتاج يعني عنايه مختلفه لما يجي لك
كذا
قاعد يفصل وعنده هرتج وعنده المعرفه هي
جامعه وسيله ايضا بس جامعه وسيله طبعا ما
يقيس كل الدول يقيس افضل الدول المتقدمه
في المجال الرقمي اعتقد انه يقيس 60 او 70
دوله
والمملكه ايضا افضل نتيجه اخذناها في
المؤشر العام الماضي يعتقد 25 مرتبه
المملكه 25 مقارنه مع اعتقد 52 او 53 في
عام 2020 فهذا ايضا في تقدم على مستوى
المنطقه الصادر من الاسكواد اللي هو
الخدمات الالكترونيه
والنقاله الحمد لله المملكه ما بين 18
دوله على مستوى المنطقه تكلم غرب اسيا
وشمال افريقيا الدول العربيه تحديدا
المملكه الافضل على مستوى العالم فاحنا في
نضج الحكومه الرقميه من بنك الدولي الافضل
على مستوى المنطقه والثالث على العالم
وايضا الاسكوا اكد انه المملكه هي الافضل
على مستوى المنطقه في يعني اتذكر مجموعه
اصدقاء على موضوع
مهددات وتحديات المرحله احنا نتكلم على
يعني اندفاع كبير ورتم سريع باتجاه رقمنه
كل الخدمات كل الاعمال شفنا ايجابياتها في
جائحه كورونا وش الجانب المظلم او
التهديدات اللي ممكن تواجه رحله التحول
الرقمي في السعوديه والله طبعا قد يكون هي
تحدي او مخاطر وبنفس الوقت فرص يعني يمكن
لو اذكر منها بذكر يمكن جانبين او ثلاث
جوانب الجانب الاول هو ضروره يعني خلق
القيمه
داخل المملكه ويكون عندنا التوطين المطلوب
يعني اليوم حنا ذكرنا عشرين مليار تصرفها
الحكومه على قطاع الاتصالات تقنيه
المعلومات طيب كم من العشرين مليار هذا
مستورد
اليوم
فرصه اي بالضبط فاليوم عندك فرصه كبيره
انك توطن وطبعا هذا المتخصصين في المجال
ما قد يبدو مفاجئ احنا نعرف انه نشتري رخص
ونشتري هاردوير وكثير من الخدمات
الاحترافيه قد تجي من خارج المملكه بس هذه
يمثل فرصه نفس الوقت وهذا بالمناسبه اللي
نعمل عليه اليوم في منظومه الاتصالات
منظومه الاتصالات اليوم لا هيئه الاتصالات
والحكومه الرقميه احنا نشوف
عندنا صندوق خاص باقراض اللي هو البرنامج
الوطني تنميه تقنيه المعلومات عندنا ايضا
برامج تدريب نعطي التدريب المطلوب وعندنا
مركز كود فهي زي التروس كده اللي تحاول
تشتغل مع بعض حتى انها تحل هذا الموضوع
عندنا مبادره في الحكومه الرقميه على
الاوبن سورس تحديدا وهذه مبادره مهمه جدا
حتى نضمن انه يكون عندنا استخدام
للتقنيات الوطنيه والتقنيات المحليه
وسوينا مستودع البرمجيات اليوم عندك تطبيق
اوبن سورس تبغى جهات الحكوميه تستفيد منه
تقدر ترفعه على المستودع وجهه اخرى تاخذ
نفس السورس كود وتشغله وهذا التوطين اللي
نحتاجه بالشكل المطلوب وايضا نشوف استثمار
الحقيقي من الشركات اليوم شفنا يعني علي
بابا موجود وركل موجوده وتقدم خدمات
سحابيه ان شاء الله ايضا قريبا راح نشوف
جوجل وراح نشوف مايكروسوفت ايضا نشوف
استثمار وحضور ايضا داخل المملكه فباذن
الله تعالى انه يعني خليني اقول هذه
الاعتماديه هو ممكن تسميها انكشاف راح تقل
واحنا عندنا مستهدفات واضحه ليس الحكومه
الرقميه فقط ولكن على مستوى المنظومه انها
ثقل بشكل كبير و الجانب الثاني طبعا
الاستدامه
المهم ان يكون عندك استدامه تبدا مشروع
مهم التشغيل يكون مستقر ولا يكون عندك
اي تحدي فيه من كل الجوانب ايضا حتى من
جانب القدرات يعني نحتاج قيادات نحتاج
مبرمجين ونحتاج مصممين ونحتاج مودر نظام
احنا بحاجه الحقيقه للكوادر بشكل كبير وهم
الحقيقه اللي بيعطونا يعني النجاح بالشكل
المطلوب وانا متفائل انه صحيح هي مخاطر
ولكن عندنا الخطط اللازمه باذن الله
لمعالجتها وبالذات انها فرص بالنسبه لفرص
لخلق قيادات فرص لاستثمارات ويعني خلق
نماذج تجاريه مثاليه باذن الله والخطر
السيبراني او خطر الهجمات
يعني اللي ممكن
تضعف الشبكه او تخترقها او يعني تدمر كثير
من مكتسبات فيها وش التعامل كيف كيف
نتلافى او نتعامل معاه احنا طبعا بلا شك
في الهيئه الوطنيه الاستبراني يعني عندهم
عمل كبير على هذا الجانب
وسيكون من الصعب جدا لاي احد انه يقول ما
في خطر سيبراني طالما انه عندك خدمات
الكترونيه هناك خطر سدراني ولكن المملكه
يعني الحمد لله عندها يعني مستوى الصمود
والرزلنس عادي جدا في هذا الجانب والمناسب
والمملكه الثانيه عالميا في مؤشر الامن
السيبراني لصادر من الاي تي يو وهذا يؤكد
انه الحمد لله يعني العمل يقومون فيه
الزملاء في الهيئه الوطنيه الامن انتم
تشتغلون يعني تعال قدم علي عشان اعطيك
ترخيص تسوي منصه هل تشترطون عليه انه يجيب
تاكيدات او ضمانات من هيئه الامن
السيبراني ولا اذا خلصت منكم يروح لهم
وشلون التكامل بينكم وبينهم الزملاء في
الهيئه الوطنيه للامن السيبراني عندهم
المعايير الاساسيه للامن السيبراني وعندهم
ايضا معايير متخصصه مثلا زي العمل عن بعد
ومنصات التواصل الاجتماعي وغيره احنا
دائما اي جهه تعمل معنا طبعا كل النماذج
الثلاثه اللي ذكرناهم قبل شوي سواء شركات
او جهات حكوميه او غيره نؤكد على اهميه
الالتزام بهذه الضوابط وطبعا الزملاء
بالامن السيبراني لا يكتفون فقط بوضع
الضوابط ولكن يتابعون الامتثال يروحون
للجهات الحكوميه ويتابعون امتثالها
ويتاكدون ان شاء الله عندنا يعني العمل
هذا بشكل مثالي طبعا اليوم الذهاب الى
تقنيات جديده يزيد الانكشاف يعني اليوم قد
يكون مستوى السيطره عندنا في يعني الفضاء
الرقمي وصل لمرحله متقدمه جدا بس انت
اليوم قاعد تشوف مثلا الذكاء الاصطناعي
كيف انه يطور قاعد تشوفه والله البلوكتشين
كيف انه قاعد يتطور او سلاسل الكتل ذكاء
الاصطناعي اليوم نشوف الذكاء الاصطناعي
التوليدي وكيف انه قاعد يغير من كثير من
الجوانب ليس فقط على قطاع التعليم ولكن
حتى على قطاعه اخرى شاهدنا نماذج انه
الذكاء الاصطناعي يستطيع انه يبرمج نفسه
وليس فقط يبرمج من خلال
شخص يعني او هيوما فبالتالي هذا يعطيك
يعني تحدي ويحتاج تنظيم مختلف ويحتاج
امتثال مختلف وهي مرحله يعني تطور مستمر
نحتاج نتاكد اننا دائما جاهزين لها هل في
عملكم
مراعاه او مسار للاشخاص
اللي ما عندهم
نضج رقمي نتكلم على كبار سن نتكلم على بعض
اصحاب الاعاقات اللي ما يقدرون يختمون
نفسهم في المنصات هذول اليوم قاعدين
يعانون معانا يعني يشعرون انهم
خارج
الدائره تماما هم لا يستطيعون يخدموا
انفسهم مضطرين يستعينون بالابن ولا الابنه
ولا احد قريب ولا في ناس يستغلون هذا
الاحتياج لرسوم معينه تعال انا انجز لك
خدمه معينه هل في توجه لمركز او مكان للي
ما يعرف يتعامل مع جواله منصه ابي اجي
اشوف انسان قدامي اخلص مع خدمتي وامشي او
يساعدني كل يعني ما شاء الله الوالده الله
يحفظها عندي 3000 رقم سري للابشر حقها كل
شوي يتغير لانها تنسى ثم تطلب وكل غاده
جمعه حيجي واحد من اخواني يحاول يساعدها
ولا الومه يعني هذا بالنسبه لهم نقله
جديده تماما
فهذا الشريحه وش الشيء اللي بيقدم لهم
خلال هالمرحله عشان ما نكون نسيناهم احنا
طبعا الشموليه احد ابرز الاهداف اللي
عندنا واليوم جزء من المعايير اللي
نتابعها على المنصات والمواقع بعض الخصائص
المميزات التي تساعد يعني هذه الفئه وطبعا
احتياجاتهم مختلفه كبير السن غير الصم غير
البكم والكل له احتياجات والكل يعني تعطى
مزايا مختلفه يعني على الموقع بحيث انك
كيف تتعامل مع الخدمات سواء في القراءه او
حتى الفويس اذا كان في اوديو وتستطيع انك
تتعامل معه بالشكل المطلي ولكن لا نزال
مقصرين ايضا هذه احد المناطق اللي نحتاج
نعمل فيها خلال فتره الجايه وعندنا ان شاء
الله برنامج قريبا بيطلق فقط لهذه الفئه
اللي قد انها تحتاج دعم ولن تكون فقط من
الحكومه الرقميه ايضا مع زملائنا في وزاره
الموارد البشريه والشؤون الاجتماعيه حتى
يكون في لها التركيز المطلوب سواء كان
تقديم المزايا والخصائص لل
المهم جدا يعني نحو المستقبل وانا ابغى
اقول الوسائل تتغير ولكن الاهداف يمكن ما
تتغير بشكل كبير الاهداف هي نفسها كفاءه
افضل وانتاجيه وايضا تجربه الوسائل تتطور
مع التقنيات الجديده ومع العمل الكبير لما
اتكلم عن التجربه زي ما تكلمنا قبل شوي
احنا تركيزنا بشكل كبير على الحكومه
الشامله توحيد التصاميم تقليل المنصات كيف
العمل يكون من خلال مكونات مشتركه وايضا
رحلات حياه مترابطه لا يهم الجهه الحكوميه
ولا يهم المنصه كيف انك انت تاخذ التجربه
المثاليه بالشكل المطلوب الانتاجيه هي بلا
شك التقنيات الناشئه اليوم
عندنا عمليه تحول كبيره باتجاه التقنيات
الناشئه احنا لا نرغب فقط يكون عندنا
منصات نرغب تكون انتاجيتنا افضل باستخدام
احدث التقنيات ولذلك وضعنا لها مؤشر خاص
وبرنامج الخاص
لمتابعته وايضا الكفاءه من خلال الشراكه
مع القطاع الخاص وتحديدا في مسار
المشتريات والاستثمار ومشاركه القطاع
الخاص نبغى كفاءتنا تكون افضل من خلال
مشاركه القطاع الخاص من خلال الاعتماد
الخدمات السحابيه واحنا بالمناسبه نستهدف
في عشرين ثلاثين انه 80% من الخدمات
الحكوميه الرقميه تكون مستضافه على
السحابات بحول الله تعالى وهدف للمرحله في
20 25 انها تكون خمسين بالمئه واليوم
اليوم تقريبا حنا حوالي 30% او 35% يعني
ما بين هالرقمين فاحنا نحتاج انه نصر ان
شاء الله الى اعتماديه اكبر عليها
وبالتالي يكون عندنا كفاءه وتركيز على
الاعمال الخاصه بالحكومه ودائما حنا نؤكد
على مركزيه المستفيد حنا اليوم تطلعات
المواطن السعودي كبيره جدا والتطلعات هي
اللي تدفعنا الى الامام بلا شك وحريصين
جدا على توفير افضل خدمات وافضل التجارب
حول الله تعالى خلال السنوات القادمه كم
رحله حيكون عندنا كم رحله عمر حنا اعتقد
انه بنوصل حوالي 15 رحله 15 رحله اهم
خدمات اللي احتاجها سواء كانت لي افراد
ولا حتى لاعمال وبالتالي يعني تعطيه
الخدمه بالشكل نصه
انا اعتقد بيكون عندنا نوعين من المنصات
منصات خدماتيه ومنصات معلوماتيه معلوماتيه
موقع عادي في اخبار في المنصات الخدماتيه
باذن الله تعالى لن تتجاوز 200 منصه وتشمل
القطاعيه وعلى حسب الاحتياج الباقي راح
يكون فقط خدماتي وبالمناسبه
وبالمناسبه يعني عندنا اليوم خدمه مهمه
جدا
اللي هي خدمه بلاغ رقمي وخدمه بلاغ رقمي
تساعدنا على الاستماع بالشكل المثالي
للمستفيدين في ثلاث انواع وشلون تشارك
طبعا من خلال مركز امن الاتصال او من خلال
منصه قبضه وهي ثلاثه انواع رئيسيه النوع
الاول اذا عندك شكوى يعني حاولت الحصول
على استجابه من الجهه مقدمه الخدمه بس ما
في استجابه تستطيع انك تتواصل وتساعد الشك
وهذا النوع الاول النوع الثاني انك تبلغ
على خدمه ورقيه تقول والله الخدمه هذه عند
الجهه الفلانيه المقدمه للخدمه لا تزال
ورقيه او طلبوا مني الحضور الى الاداره او
الجهه المسؤوله داخل هذه الجهاز والنوع
الثالث فيه خدمه رقميه ولكن عندك فكره
لتطويرها تحس انه والله بعتقد تصميمها
ممكن يكون افضل تقليل عدد الخطوات
الاعتماد مثلا على السمات حيويه اعطنا
اقتراحك فاليوم ندعو الجميع الحقيقه على
الاستفاده من رقمي ويعني رفع كل الافكار
ولا سمح الله اي شكاوي او بلاغات يعني
نحتاج نتعامل معها وهذا التواصل وهذه
الشراكه والمشاركه الالكترونيه المطلوبه
الحقيقه مع كل المستفيدين احنا المفروض في
عشرين ثلاثين افضل خمس دول اللي اليوم
احنا ترجمنا واحد وثلاثين صح في هذا
المؤشر واحد وثلاثين في هذا المؤشر بس في
مؤشر اخر احنا الثالث اللي هو نضج الحكومه
الرقميه
نوصل انا اعتقد ان احنا وصلنا اليوم في
نضج الحكومه الرقميه اللي هو صادم البنك
الدولي في مؤشر تطور الحكومه الالكترونيه
بلا شك يعني اعتقد انه فرصه قائمه بشكل
كبير انه نكون باذن الله من افضل خمس دول
خليني اختم اقول
مش الفرق بين مقابلتنا الاولى في سبتمبر
كوكيل وزاره الماليه ذلك الوقت مسؤول عن
منصه اعتماد وبين مقابلاتنا اليوم مع
معالي محافظ هيئه الحكميه انت ما خليتني
اقول شيء عن وزاره الماليه المناسبه ايه
يعني وزاره الماليه ما ننساهم يعني زملاء
يقومون ومستمرين بالقيام بعمل رائع جدا
معالي ابو فيصل الجدعان وفريقه في منظومه
الماليه واعتماد اليوم يتطور بشكل كبير
بالمناسبه الى مركز نظم مركز الوطني لنظم
الموارد الحكوميه وهذا فريد يمكن ما بين
حكومات حول العالم وهذا المركز يساعد بشكل
كبير
الايرادات ويدير الرواتب ويدير يعني اعمال
كبيره يعني تخص الحكومه اليوم اللي وصل
على منصه اعتماد كعدد من حيث عدد
المنافسات المطروحه تقريبا 850 الف منافسه
اللي مطروح من بدايه المنصه في بدايه 2018
حنا قريبين من مليون بتشوف حجم الفرص اللي
اليوم تقدمها المنصه للقطاع الخاص ومستوى
الشفافيه العالي قلبك مع اعتماد ما زال
انا كنت في الدنمارك قبل اسابيع والتقيت
مع وزاره الماليه المسؤولين في وزاره
الماليه الدنماركيه
الدنمارك عمر
افضل دوله في المؤشر الخاص بتطور الحكومه
الكترونيه من اليون افضل دوله
في الدنمارك وكنا نتحدث عن عمليه اعداد
الميزانيه وتحديدا في المناقشات كنت
اسالهم شلون تبدون المناقشات مع الجهات
وتحددون التكاليف المطلوبه اللي تبين
كالتالي لا يوجد دوره رقميه من
الطرح الى الشراء الى الدفع عند الدنمارك
كل جهه تعمل وحدها بعض الجهات عندها خدمات
رقميه بعض الجهات ما عندها فلا تتوفر
لديهم لا يوجد لدى وزاره الماليه هناك سجل
موحد للعقود والالتزامات سالتها قلت اول
ما تبدا تناقش تبي تقول وين العقود وين
السجل حتى اني استطيع اعرف التكاليف
والتزامات اللي عليك لا يوجد يعتمد على
المدخلات من الجهه الحكوميه وايضا لا يمكن
الدفع بشكل مباشر من القطاع الخاص اليوم
في منصه اعتماد بقياده الزملاء المتميزين
حتى القطاع الخاص يرفع على المنصه
الفواتير وهذا غير موجود في كثير من دول
العالم المتقدم من يوم القطاع الخاص يدخل
على منصه اعتماد وهو اللي يقوم برفع
الفواتير في اليوم بلا شك في تميز كبير بس
النشيد فيها وعشان ما ننساهم ويعني ما في
شكلهم فضل كبير بعمليه التطوير وهم جزء من
الحكومه الرقميه الفرق كبير طبعا اليوم
احنا كنا نتكلم عن الماليه العامه اليوم
كل القطاعات سابقا الماليه العامه
والتشغيل اليوم تنظيم واشراف وكل القطاعات
واليوم يمكن عمل كبير على المؤشرات
الدوليه بدعم الجميع وهي رحله مستمره يعني
ويمكن اليوم ثاني لقاء معك ولكن ان شاء
الله يكون معك لقاء ثالث قبل عشرين ثلاثين
باذن الله باذن الله تعالى بصفه شكرا على
قبول الدعوه
تساعدنا في اقناع باقي قيادات متاكد
ونتشرف بك باذن الله الله يعطيك الصحه
وشرفتني الساعه الله يحفظك تسلم شكرا لكم
وشكرا فهد القصير في اعداد وانتاج الحلقه
ياسر ال غانم في اداره التصوير ياسر كدشه
مساعد اضاءه وفي تصوير الكواليس عبد
الرحمن عبود في تسجيل الصوت عبد العزيز
المزي وفي الاخراج الفني مجد القرشي وفي
التحرير انس الخليل وفي الهندسه الصوتيه
محمد الحسن وفي الاشراف على الانتاج غيداء
التميمي واصيل بافرط هذا بودكاست سقراط
احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]